hey Theo what's up this is Blake from
Atlanta Atlanta onward and I've been
thinking about pies I've been thinking
about pumpkin pie and I've been thinking
about you know pean pie because I've
heard of both of those pies oh yeah man
and I know you I love pie and I don't
know if you knew that or not before you
called but man I love
pie cuz a pie is
just a pie just looks up at a cake and
it's like hey look at all the [__]
beautiful [__] I
did in just an inch and a half
[__] you up there it's like
watching a Mexican dude do well in
basketball that's a pie and he looking
up all the there these all these cakes
all these German chocolate heads six
story nine story they got Euro players
these you know tiramasu hitting them
from the threes and that and doing them
baby gator shots and all of that [__]
off the back
top and then they got your
boy little
ector you know ector pis Uno bro and
he's that pie baby and he gets it all
done at the bottom of the bowl and I
respect that 100% I love pies and I I'm
just a shocked you even knew that I was
thinking about him as much because it's
so crazy as soon as Halloween once that
pumpkin strikes
midnight and Cinderella gets out that
[__] I got pie in my sky baby let's
hear more so you've heard of pumpkin
pies and you've heard of pecan pies but
what but I've never heard of pump Canin
pie that's something I've never heard of
what do you mean and that'd be like a
little half and half pumpkin pie half
pumpkin half
T So I was
thinking about
that pie and I was thinking is that
something that you would be interested
in is that something that you would try
or are you more like a pie
traditionalist and you don't think that
we need to be melding different types of
Pies so thank you for taking my call and
happy Halloween oh man I think you on to
something that pump can huh and that's
uplifting too cuz pump K dude that's Ken
that means anybody you know you have a
piece of pie next you know you you know
you and your cousin [__] sharing
whipped cream you know you sharing the
toppings on each other and that's
pumpkin but pump can now you and your
cousin starting a small business and I
love that that pumpkin peon boom boom
that's a diversity you know I like that
little you know that that little pie
that pie movement yeah I love pies man
and you know you know what's funny now
that you say it I do need to Branch out
because I've been so convicted to Apple
and I've been so convicted I [__]
dude you show me a peach dude I swear to
God you show me a peach cobbler you had
a peach cobbler in the woods maybe I
would say up to 60 ft off the interstate
even behind a couple trees and I'll
still be able to see that [__] driving
at 65 miles
hour I will still be able to see that
thing boy my eyes are Keen to a cobbler
baby I got that cobble wobble in my face
son you know what I'm saying I see a
dessert and I you know I just can't even
handle myself I see a cob dude gas
station I'll be a full tank bro I'll be
driving by it I'm I don't need any gas I
see peach cobbler
215 a quarter pound bro
yeah dude this thing ain't even a Tesla
on this [__] is doing automatic
u-turns I be uing up in that gas all
right I'm pumping gas the tank is full
bro I'm filling the back seat up with
gas I don't give a [__] I want an excuse
to get that here
and that's that cobbler
BR dude my neck goes limp around a
cobbler I can't dude I got to have two
two you know two shorties two beautiful
little uh Southern you know little
biscuit babies in there to hold me up
while I while I order it cuz I'm my neck
goes limp around a
cobbler cuz a cobbler they basically
just took a peach pie put that [__] in
the streets for a few weeks and taught
that thing how to twerk baby and that's
a cobbler boy and I do that cble
wobble I'm a cobbler son I'm fitting
shoes for my sweet tooth son I love
cobbler but yeah I appreciate you
calling about
that